Jordan did not love the idea of coming into the studio to tell this next story. The very first thing he said to me when he sat down was--
对于参与录制下一段故事，Jordan并不是很感兴趣。他坐下后跟我说的第一句话是——
I am curious-- of all the stories, why this story? Because it's not my particularly proudest story.
我很好奇——在所有的故事里，为什么要选这个？因为这并不是我最引以为傲的故事。
In fact, the only reason that he agreed to the interview is that he's good friends with the little brother of one of our producers, Miki. They all grew up together. And this story happened when he was going into his senior year of high school in small town Utah. Jordan and his buddies all lived together in a house that summer, daring each other into Jackass style pranks and stunts.
事实上，他之所以同意接受采访，完全是因为他与我们制片人Miki的弟弟是好朋友。他们是一起长大的。这个故事发生在高中最后一年，地点在犹他州的一个小镇。那个夏天，Jordan和他的哥们儿住在一起，他们总是互相怂恿，玩一些类似《蠢蛋搞怪秀》(Jackass)风格的恶作剧和特技。
For instance, there's this time they drove a car into an orchard. There's the bike accident that gave Jordan one huge swollen testicle. There's the time they peed into a 7 Up can, and Miki's mom accidentally drank out of it.
比如，有一次他们把车开进了果园。还有一次自行车事故，导致Jordan的一个睾丸肿得很大。还有一次，他们往7 Up汽水罐里撒尿，Miki的妈妈不小心喝了下去。
I'll tell you it was not my pee in the 7 UP can.
我得告诉你，那罐7 Up里的尿不是我的。
All right.
好吧。
And I feel like to talk on public radio, there's a part of me that would rather tell America at large about my swollen testicles story. But this is the one that I feel I tell the least.
我觉得在公共广播电台讲话，我宁愿告诉全美国关于我睾丸肿胀的故事。但这个故事是我觉得最少提及的。
The story that he tells the least-- the one that he's about to tell you right now-- is about how he did not become Mr. Genola in the Mr. Genola contest. Genola is a farming town, population 1,300. And the contest was a pageant for guys. There was no Miss Genola pageant. And it was a brand new tradition, only in its second year, and it was not a serious contest. Like the winner the first year, for the talent competition, ate a frozen burrito while it was still frozen. Like, that was his talent.
他最少提及的故事——也就是他马上要讲给你们听的——是关于他在“Genola先生”比赛中是如何没能获胜的。Genola是一个农业小镇，人口1300。这个比赛是针对男性的选美。这里没有“Genola小姐”比赛。这还是一个全新的传统，才举办到第二年，而且并不是一场严肃的比赛。比如第一年的冠军，在才艺展示环节吃了一个冷冻布里托，还是没解冻的那种。这就是他的才艺。
Jordan's friend, who was also named Jordan, had competed that first year wearing a blow up butterfly float during the swimsuit competition and singing Pearl Jam to his dead frog in the talent section.
Jordan的朋友（也叫Jordan）在第一年也参加了比赛，他在泳装环节穿着充气蝴蝶浮具，在才艺展示环节对着他的死青蛙唱Pearl Jam的歌。
And he's deciding that we're going to enter the Mr. Genola content and volunteers me to be the participant, the single participant out of our house.
他决定我们要参加“Genola先生”比赛，并自告奋勇让我作为参赛者，也就是我们住的那栋房子里的唯一参赛者。
And just so you can picture this-- they did have an audience of a couple hundred people, because it was scheduled as part of the annual Genola Day celebration. Which has a rodeo, and a greased pig chase, and a town dinner, and a parade.
为了让你们有画面感——当时确实有几百名观众，因为它是年度Genola日庆典的一部分。庆典包括牛仔竞技表演、油腻小猪追逐赛、镇上晚宴和游行。
And in the middle of a public park, they took a bunch of wood apple bins and flipped them over, and put some plywood across it and made a stage. And then, probably eight contestants, all high schoolers--
在公园中央，他们把一堆木制苹果箱翻过来，铺上胶合板搭了一个舞台。大约有八名参赛者，全都是高中生——
We're honored to be the MCs for the Mr. Genola pageant. We hope you understand this pageant is not a scholarship pageant.
我们很荣幸担任“Genola先生”选美比赛的主持人。希望你们理解，这不是一场奖学金选美比赛。
In the video of this, you can see two teenaged MCs dressed in spoof awards show wear-- a girl in a checkered jacket with a comically wide lapel, and a boy in formal tails and a vest, no shirt at all, bow tie, and cowboy hat. Jordan and I went right to the part where he comes on stage.
在这段视频里，你可以看到两名十几岁的主持人穿着模仿颁奖典礼的服装——女孩穿着格纹外套，翻领宽得滑稽，男孩穿着正式的燕尾服和背心，没穿衬衫，戴着领结和牛仔帽。Jordan和我直接跳到了他上台的部分。
Our fifth contestant is Jordan Alberto Riley, son of Alan and Kris Riley. We couldn't find anything special about him.
我们的第五位选手是Jordan Alberto Riley，Alan和Kris Riley的儿子。我们没发现他有什么特别之处。
So they just announced me. And you know, it's a small town. They tell me who my parents are. And I come up on the stage, and I'm wearing a shirt with sleeves cut off, and I've got some long hair and a hat. And then I bring up a wheelchair.
就这样他们宣布了我。你知道，那是个小镇。他们报出了我父母的名字。我走上舞台，穿着一件袖子剪掉的衬衫，留着长发，戴着帽子。然后我推上了一把轮椅。
[CROWD CLAMORING]
[人群喧哗声]
Jordan had used a wheelchair for a little while after an injury once. Now he starts showing off the tricks he learned then-- popping wheelies and spinning.
Jordan曾经因伤使用过一段时间轮椅。现在他开始炫耀那时学到的技巧——翘起前轮和旋转。
I just was spinning faster and faster, until me and the wheelchair all spun off to the side, tumbling backwards.
我只是越转越快，直到我和轮椅一起被甩向侧面，向后翻滚。
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
After a few more wheelies, Jordan gets up from the chair, flexes his muscles. Heavy metal music kicks in.
又表演了几个翘轮动作后，Jordan从椅子上站起来，展示他的肌肉。重金属音乐响起。
[HEAVY METAL MUSIC PLAYING]
[重金属音乐播放中]
And his buddies carry an old door onstage, this door that has a big pane of glass in the top third. Jordan grabs the mike to explain what's going to happen.
他的朋友们搬来一扇旧门放在舞台上，门的上三分之一处有一块大玻璃。Jordan抢过麦克风解释即将发生什么。
I'm pretty much just breaking a window. That's about it.
我基本上就是打碎一扇窗户。就这么简单。
Now, I'm pumping myself up by flexing and shaking my head. And I run at it and give it a good punch through the window. And then I stepped back, and I looked at this window, and there was a triangular piece of glass right in the middle of it. And I looked at that, and I thought, that's funny. I don't remember that glass having blood on it before I punched through it. And stepped back, and I'm just looking at the audience, and I looked down-- down right at my forearm, like almost to my elbow. And there was a hole. And like, in that moment in time, it was like when things go in slow motion.
现在，我通过展示肌肉和甩头让自己兴奋起来。我冲过去，对着窗户重重地打了一拳。然后我退后一步，看着这扇窗，中间有一块三角形的玻璃碎片。我看着它，心想，真有意思。我记得我打穿它之前，玻璃上没血。我往后退，看着观众，然后低头一看——看向我的前臂，几乎直到手肘处。那里有个洞。在那一瞬间，就像一切都变成了慢动作。
I remember a severed muscle hanging out. And I'm looking at my forearm, and I think about this time that we went hiking in the Narrows of Zion's national park. And I was carrying a Rambo knife, and I went to go catch a snake. And I cut the side of this snake in his-- you can see some stuff coming out this gash, which I immediately regretted. But I stood there, and I thought about that snake as I looked at my forearm.
我记得有一块断裂的肌肉露在外面。我看着我的前臂，想起有一次我们在锡安国家公园的窄路徒步。我带着一把兰博刀，想去抓蛇。我不小心切开了那条蛇的侧面，看到一些东西从伤口里流出来，我当时立刻就后悔了。但我站在那里，看着我的前臂时，想到了那条蛇。
Yeah.
是的。
And then it seemed like, bam! Fast motion happens. And I turn around, and blood is just splatting on the floor. And the MC steps in. And I'm showing her my arm, and I'm saying, call an ambulance! And she says, is that real?
然后，砰！一切变成了快动作。我转过身，血喷溅在地板上。主持人走过来。我给她看我的手臂，说，叫救护车！她说，那是真的吗？
Oh, she thought it was a prank. She thought you were just like-- you have fake blood or something.
哦，她以为是恶作剧。她以为你只是——你用了假血之类的东西。
Oh, totally. Everybody did. And then one of my friends tears off his t-shirt and then tourniquets around it. They're like, he's turning white. He's turning white. Just lay him down.
哦，完全是。每个人都这么认为。然后我一个朋友撕下他的T恤，帮我止血。他们喊着，他脸色变白了！他脸色变白了！快让他躺下。
Kids start rushing the stage to see. We actually talked to one of those kids, who's grown now. And he said that he figured it was fake blood and a really cool prank. And then he got near and saw that it was real. And the next thing he knew, he was waking up under a tree with an oxygen mask. Jordan and his friends believe a few people fainted.
孩子们开始冲向舞台观看。我们确实采访了其中一个孩子，他现在已经长大了。他说他当时以为那是假血，是一场非常酷的恶作剧。直到他走近看到那是真的。下一刻，他发现自己在树下醒来，戴着氧气面罩。Jordan和他的朋友们相信有几个人晕倒了。
Ladies and gentlemen, we're getting as cleaned up as soon as we can. Please, that happened totally on accident. I didn't know he was doing that, and we probably wouldn't have allowed it. So for the judges' information, we're going to have Mike Huell go before Clark Davis, because Mike's singing and Clark's dancing. So we can let the stage dry for a minute.
女士们先生们，我们正尽可能清理现场。请注意，那完全是个意外。我不知道他在做那个，我们可能根本不会允许的。所以，评委们请注意，接下来是Mike Huell，然后是Clark Davis，因为Mike要唱歌，Clark要跳舞。我们可以让舞台晾干一会儿。
Jordan says that this girl MC, later, said how mad she was that he ruined her pageant. But at this moment, she and the other teenaged MC had to ad-lib their way through this situation that I think even a very experienced public speaker would find challenging. There's a man on stage with them mopping up blood-- like with a mop, there's so much blood. And they have to fill time.
Jordan说那个女主持人后来表示，她非常生气他毁了她的选美。但在那一刻，她和另一位少年主持人不得不临场发挥，应对这种我认为即使是非常有经验的公共演讲者也会觉得极具挑战性的情况。舞台上有一个人正在用拖把清理血迹——真的是用拖把，血太多了。他们必须填补时间。
All right. Um, well, how's the show so far?
好的。呃，那么，目前的表演感觉如何？
[LAUGHTER AND CHEERING]
[笑声和欢呼声]
That goes over surprisingly well. And so to stall for time, they run through what apparently is the only standby material they have. The boy onstage pulls out a fistful of pages.
效果好得令人惊讶。为了拖延时间，他们用了显然是他们唯一的备用稿。台上的男孩掏出一把纸。
All right. Here's something a man named John put on his answering machine. It says, hi, this is John. If you are the phone company, I already sent the money. If you are my parents, please send money. If you are my friends, you owe me money. If you are a female, don't worry. I have plenty of money.
好的。这是一位名叫John的人留在他电话留言机上的内容。他说，嗨，我是John。如果你是电话公司，我已经寄钱了。如果你是我父母，请寄钱给我。如果你是我朋友，你欠我钱。如果你是女性，别担心。我有很多钱。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Here's another one. Hi, I am probably home. I just-- I'm just--
还有这一条。嗨，我可能在家。我只是——我只是——
They never did another Mr. Genola contest. This pretty much killed it off. The ambulance came. Jordan didn't lose an arm. He's fine. He's in his 30s now. And the phrase that he uses for what he's become now is "contributing member of society." He settled down. He's a farmer-- grows apples, cherries, peaches-- with a family, a young daughter. He hasn't lived in Genola since that summer. But now and then-- this just happened at a farm stand a month ago-- he runs into people who say to him, aren't you the guy who almost cut off his arm in that pageant? That's what they know him for.
他们再也没有举办过Genola先生比赛。这件事基本上让它夭折了。救护车来了。Jordan没有丢掉手臂。他没事。他现在30多岁了。他用“社会贡献者”这个词来形容现在的自己。他安定下来了。他是个农民——种苹果、樱桃、桃子——有家庭，有一个年幼的女儿。从那个夏天起他就再没住在Genola。但偶尔——就在一个月前在一个农产品摊位上——他会遇到人们对他说，你就是那个在选美比赛中差点切断手臂的家伙吗？这就是人们认识他的原因。
Well, in the town of Genola, that's my badge to wear.
嗯，在Genola镇，这就是我的勋章。
Yeah.
是的。
They know me as the guy who did the Mr. Genola pageant.
他们认识我作为那个参加Genola先生选美的人。
It's been over a decade, and he still doesn't ever watch this video. Too soon. Still makes him wince. I asked him when he will be able to watch this and not wince, and he said he thinks it pretty much always will be too soon for this one.
十多年过去了，他仍然从来不看这段视频。为时过早。还是会让他退缩。我问他什么时候能看这段视频而不感到退缩，他说他觉得这一辈子对这个视频来说都太早了。
Yeah. Like I said, this was not the proudest story. And just seeing us at that time, in those teenage-- it's just painful to watch. I'm not a fan of that guy.
是的。就像我说的，这并不是我最自豪的故事。看着当时的我们，在那十几岁的年纪——看那个真的很痛苦。我不喜欢那个家伙。
Today on our radio program-- "Too Soon." Sometimes it will always be too soon. But sometimes, you can imagine a world where the thing that you're remembering really will become much less of a big deal, and you'll be able to think about it without cringing. If you're lucky, maybe it'll even start to seem funny. We have two stories for you today. In each of them, there's a piece of video that is capturing a moment. And in each of them, the past crashes against the present in this way that is really kind of mesmerizing.
今天在我们的广播节目中——“太早了”。有时它永远都会是太早。但有时，你可以想象一个世界，你记忆中的那件事真的变得没那么重要了，你可以不用退缩地回想它。如果幸运的话，它甚至可能会开始变得好笑。今天我们有两个故事要讲给你们听。在每个故事中，都有一段捕捉瞬间的视频。在每个故事中，过去以一种非常迷人的方式与现在碰撞。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》(This American Life)。我是Ira Glass。请继续收听。
So Jordan's story was about a prank gone wrong. And you say this next story is like that, too. Except, in this next story, it is not just one prank. And "wrong" does not capture the sheer wrongness of what you're about to hear. Nancy Updike tells the story.
所以Jordan的故事是关于一个弄巧成拙的恶作剧。你说这下一个故事也差不多。只是，在下一个故事中，不仅仅是一个恶作剧。而且“弄巧成拙”这个词根本无法形容你即将听到的事情的荒谬程度。Nancy Updike来讲这个故事。
And I should say, before we start-- if you're listening to this on our podcast or online, we have unbeeped some curse words in the internet version of this story. If you want to listen with your kids in the car, or you just don't like curse words, there's a beeped version available at our website, thisamericanlife.org. OK. Here's Nancy.
我得说一下，在我们开始之前——如果你是在我们的播客或网上收听，我们在网络版本中保留了原本的粗俗语言。如果你想和孩子在车里收听，或者你不喜欢粗俗语言，我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 上有消音版本。好的。请听Nancy讲述。
Harmon Leon is a writer and comedian whose cocktail party story about "the weirdest gig I ever did" is a more weird, by a lot, than anyone else's that I've heard. He answered an ad for a job several years ago that called for a comedian who would be the hilarious sidekick to a celebrity on a new, hidden camera prank TV show.
Harmon Leon是一位作家和喜剧演员，他关于“我做过最诡异的工作”的酒会故事，比我听过的任何人的都要诡异得多。几年前，他应聘了一份工作，招聘要求是找一名喜剧演员，在一部全新的隐藏摄像机恶作剧电视节目中担任名人的搞笑搭档。
It was on the Los Angeles Craigslist ad. And I'm thinking, oh, it's a celebrity hidden camera show. I've done a bunch of prank stuff. So I sent him my prank reel. I got the job, and they said they couldn't disclose who the celebrity was.
那是在洛杉矶的Craigslist广告上看到的。我想，哦，这是一个名人隐藏摄像机节目。我做过很多恶作剧节目。所以我寄去了我的恶作剧样片。我得到了那份工作，他们说不能透露那位名人是谁。
Harmon rolled his eyes.
Harmon翻了个白眼。
Well, just people say that as like, oh, when we tell you who the celebrity is, you're not going to believe it. You're not going to believe it. And your mind just goes, you know, you're jaded--
嗯，人们总会那样说，比如，哦，当我们告诉你名人是谁时，你不会相信的。你绝对不会相信。你的大脑只会想，你知道，你已经麻木了——
Eh, I'll probably believe it, you think.
嗯，我想我可能会相信的，你会想。
Yeah, yeah. It's like, is it like the other Hilton sister? Or is it Vanilla Ice? My bar was so low to what it actually turned out to be.
是的，是的。就像，难道是希尔顿姐妹中的另一位？还是Vanilla Ice？我的预期底线低到没想到最后竟然是那个人。
Yeah.
是的。
And they go, OK, are you ready?
他们说，OK，你准备好了吗？
Are you ready? Because it's O.J. Simpson. A prank show with O.J. Simpson. Harmon thought, that's a terrible idea for a TV show, and I'm definitely taking this job.
你准备好了吗？因为是O.J. Simpson。一个有O.J. Simpson的恶作剧节目。Harmon想，这真是个糟糕的电视节目主意，我一定要接这份工作。
So the shooting was in a week. So I drove down from San Francisco to LA. I get out of my car. I go to the production office. And the first thing the producer says to me-- "you know, Harmon, we really can't mention the murders."
拍摄在一周后。我从旧金山开车去洛杉矶。我下车，去了制作办公室。制片人对我说的第一句话是——“你知道，Harmon，我们真的不能提及那些谋杀案。”
OK. Anyone over 30, please bear with me for a minute. And for the under 30s, here's the O.J. Simpson recap. Handsome, charming, famous football player, Heisman Trophy winner whose nickname was "Juice." After he retired, became even more famous doing commercials, Monday Night Football , movies, TV shows, Saturday Night Live .
好的。任何30岁以上的人，请容忍我一分钟。对于30岁以下的人，这是O.J. Simpson的回顾。英俊、迷人、著名的橄榄球运动员，海斯曼奖杯得主，绰号“Juice”（果汁）。退役后，他通过广告、周一橄榄球之夜、电影、电视节目和《周六夜现场》变得更加出名。
And here's the part you probably do know, even if you think you know nothing. In 1994, he was accused of killing his ex-wife, Nicole Simpson and another person, Ron Goldman. You know that because he became a national obsession. 95 million people, give or take, watched the live broadcast of his white Bronco driving the LA freeways with police cars chasing him. That was more than the Superbowl audience that year. 150 million watched the verdict in the trial where he was acquitted of the murders.
还有你可能知道的部分，即使你认为你一无所知。1994年，他被指控杀害了前妻Nicole Simpson和另一个人Ron Goldman。你知道这一点，因为他成了全国性的痴迷对象。大概有9500万人观看了他那辆白色Bronco在洛杉矶高速公路上行驶、警车在后面追逐的直播。那比那一年的超级碗观众还要多。1.5亿人观看了他在谋杀案中被判无罪的审判判决。
This prank show was being filmed about 10 years after that. O.J. Simpson had been mostly out of the public eye for those years. Most Americans at that time, 78%, believed he either probably or definitely killed his ex-wife and Ron Goldman. He lost a civil suit that had found them liable for the deaths. And so--
这个恶作剧节目大约是在那之后的10年拍摄的。在那几年里，O.J. Simpson大部分时间都在公众视线之外。当时大多数美国人（78%）认为他很可能或绝对杀害了他的前妻和Ron Goldman。他在一场民事诉讼中败诉，被认定对这些死亡负有责任。所以——
This would be the next step in his career-- doing a zany, hidden camera prank show entitled Juiced.
这将是他职业生涯的下一步——制作一个名为《Juiced》的荒诞隐藏摄像机恶作剧节目。
["JUICED" THEME SONG]
[《Juiced》主题曲]
Incredibly, this exists. It was a one-time special on Pay Per View. Just one episode, about an hour long. And I've got the DVD on my desk right now. Here's the description on the cover. Quote, "witness O.J. Simpson performing hilarious practical jokes and shocking hidden camera stunts on unsuspecting real life people all across America. No one is safe, because the juice is loose again."
令人难以置信的是，它确实存在。这是一个在按次付费电视(Pay Per View)上播放的特别节目。只有一集，大约一个小时长。我的桌子上现在就有这张DVD。封面上是这样描述的。引用：“亲眼见证O.J. Simpson在全美范围内对毫无防备的普通人进行搞笑的恶作剧和令人震惊的隐藏摄像机特技。没有人是安全的，因为Juice又放出来了。”
My first question when I saw it was, why does this exist? Which is a dumb question. Reality shows exist because they're cheap to make and people watch them. Maybe a better question is, why isn't this hidden camera prank show from 2006 as well known and scrutinized as every other part of O.J. Simpson's public life? I'm here to say, I think it's worth a look.
我看到它时的第一个问题是，这东西为什么存在？这是个愚蠢的问题。真人秀的存在是因为制作成本低，而且有人看。也许更好的问题是，为什么这个2006年的隐藏摄像机恶作剧节目不像O.J. Simpson公众生活的其他部分那样广为人知并受到审视？我在这里想说，我认为它值得一看。
Here's a show that was never meant to be taken seriously. And because of that, we get these strange, revealing glimpses of O.J. Goofing around in front of the camera, chatting with strangers, riffing. It's an hour with him unlike any hour you've ever seen. I also think it might be the most mystifying celebrity comeback vehicle ever made.
这是一档从未打算认真对待的节目。正因如此，我们得以看到O.J.一些奇怪而深刻的片段。他在摄像机前胡闹，与陌生人聊天，即兴发挥。这是你见过的最不像任何其他节目的一个小时。我还认为这可能是历史上最令人费解的名人复出工具。
The show is a whole bunch of short prank scenarios, one after another, in different locations-- fast food place, golf course, bingo parlor. Sometimes O.J. is in disguise. Sometimes he's not. The idea was O.J. Would be someplace doing something, and Harmon's job was to help piss off the people around him. Or in prank show lingo--
节目是由一连串短暂的恶作剧场景组成的，地点各不相同——快餐店、高尔夫球场、宾果游戏厅。有时O.J.戴着伪装。有时没有。构思是O.J.会在某个地方做某事，而Harmon的工作是帮助激怒周围的人。或者用恶作剧节目的行话来说——
Try to elevate the action.
试图提升冲突。
Exactly. For instance, on a golf course.
正是如此。比如，在高尔夫球场上。
So the gag was O.J. Will keep golfing with his friends. And then I run on the golf course with a video camera pretending I'm paparazzi trying to film O.J.
所以那个梗是O.J.会和他的朋友们继续打高尔夫。然后我拿着摄像机冲上高尔夫球场，假装我是狗仔队，试图拍摄O.J.。
There was no script. Also, sometimes, not even a road map. Sometimes the producer would jump into the scene himself to elevate the action even more. Or, mercifully, to help conclude it, like at the golf course.
没有剧本。而且，有时连大致方向都没有。有时制片人会亲自跳进场景中以进一步提升冲突。或者，谢天谢地，帮助结束它，就像在高尔夫球场那样。
That just ended with me and the producer of Juiced rolling around on the golf course wrestling. Because we didn't know how to end it.
那场戏最后我和《Juiced》的制片人在高尔夫球场上滚作一团打架。因为我们不知道怎么收场。
Here's the thing. Pranks might be a misleadingly precise term for what happens in the show. It's more like low-level harassment of random civilians. And also, O.J. Simpson is here! Let me walk you through one prank to show you how it goes. This one starts, like all of them do, with O.J. Simpson just dressed as himself, sitting in a chair, explaining the idea for the upcoming scene.
问题就在这里。恶作剧可能是一个具有误导性的精确术语，用来描述节目中发生的事情。它更像是对普通平民的低级别骚扰。而且，O.J. Simpson竟然就在这里！让我带你过一遍一个恶作剧，看看它是怎么进行的。这一个像所有恶作剧一样，以O.J. Simpson穿着自己的衣服，坐在一张椅子上，解释即将到来的场景的构思开始。
Set up a situation at an open house. I was visiting the house, looking for a house with my alleged girlfriend.
在开放参观日设定一个情况。我当时正在参观那所房子，和我的所谓女朋友一起找房子。
Then Harmon jumps in to explain his role in the scene.
然后Harmon跳出来解释他在场景中的角色。
I played disgruntled house owner. And then I played a party guy.
我扮演的是不满的房主。然后我还扮演了一个派对狂。
And then the prank starts. The scene for this prank, like O.J. said, is an open house. There's a realtor. She's in on the prank.
然后恶作剧开始了。正如O.J.所说，这个恶作剧的场景是一个房屋开放参观。有一位房地产经纪人。她参与了恶作剧。
Hi. Come on in.
嗨。进来吧。
Tall, long blonde hair, strapless top. It's all very Southern California. And she's showing it to people, including a couple named Kristie and O.J.
高个子，长金发，无肩带上衣。非常有南加州的风格。她带着人们参观，其中包括一对叫Kristie和O.J.的夫妇。
Hi, O.J. It's nice to meet you.
嗨，O.J.。很高兴见到你。
It's O.J. Simpson.
是O.J. Simpson。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
I was getting ready to say, he looks just like O.J. Simpson.
我当时正准备说，他长得真像O.J. Simpson。
Another woman and a man who are also looking at the house recognize O.J. right away, and they shake his hand warmly. They're surprised that he's there, but not weirded out. And then they all keep looking at the house. Then the realtor who, again, is part of the prank, knocks over a vase--
另一位女士和一位也在看房的男士一眼就认出了O.J.，并热情地握了他的手。他们很惊讶他出现在这里，但并没有感到奇怪。然后他们继续参观房子。接着，参与恶作剧的房地产经纪人打碎了一个花瓶——
[VASE SHATTERING]
[花瓶破碎声]
--and blames one of the people looking at the house.
——并指责其中一个看房的人。
He broke it.
他弄碎的。
Then Harmon, playing the homeowner, comes out and gets angry.
然后Harmon扮演的房主走出来，表现得很生气。
Why are you coming into my house and breaking my things?
你们为什么要进我的家，弄碎我的东西？
I'm sorry. Gary--
我很抱歉。Gary——
Then there's an argument, or an attempt at one. But a lot of people are just more patient and reasonable than you think they're going to be, so it doesn't go anywhere.
然后就发生了争吵，或者说试图争吵。但很多人比你预想的要更有耐心和通情达理，所以事情并没有进展下去。
She broke it accidentally, and people have accidents, and you need to calm down.
她是意外弄碎的，人们都会有意外，你需要冷静下来。
I work with this Realtor, and she doesn't lie to me.
我和这位房地产经纪人共事，她不会对我撒谎。
Then the camera cuts to a topless woman. Who is topless, outside, jumping on a trampoline. Which the Realtor works into the sell.
然后摄像机切到一个上身赤裸的女人身上。她在外面蹦床上跳。房地产经纪人将其作为卖点。
The backyard is fabulous for entertaining.
后院非常适合娱乐。
And which O.J. jumps in to comment on.
O.J.跳出来评论。
Geez. Well, it's looking rather entertaining to me.
天哪。嗯，我觉得看起来确实很娱乐。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Then the topless woman enters the house, swishes her way through everyone. There's a quick cut to her running through the house, in slow motion. Then another broken vase--
然后那个赤裸上身的女人进入房子，在所有人身边穿梭。镜头快速剪辑到她在房子里慢动作奔跑。接着又是另一个破碎的花瓶——
[VASE SHATTERING]
[花瓶破碎声]
Oh, Jesus!
哦，天哪！
--another accusation, another vase. Then the guy who's in on the prank throws up.
——另一个指控，另一个花瓶。然后参与恶作剧的那个家伙呕吐了。
[VOMITING]
[呕吐声]
Oh, Jesus man. [INAUDIBLE] come on. Jesus, man.
哦，老兄。拜托了。天哪，伙计。
If this makes no sense to you, you're following it perfectly. I've shown this prank to a lot of people. And every time, they look at me helplessly, like, what's going on here? Who's even getting pranked?
如果这对你来说毫无意义，那你完全跟上了节奏。我给很多人看过这个恶作剧。每一次，他们都无奈地看着我，心想，这到底在搞什么？到底谁被恶作剧了？
There are interesting moments in the scene, when a few people looking at the house notice O.J. and react to him. One couple is signing in at the kitchen counter, and the woman whispers to the man. It's so quiet they had to put subtitles on the screen. She whispers, "O.J. Simpson just came in." Then she says, "did you hear me? O.J. Simpson is right behind you." The guy with her glances over, and then they just keep looking around.
场景中有些有趣的时刻，当一些看房的人注意到O.J.并对他做出反应时。一对夫妇在厨房柜台签到，女的对男的耳语。声音太小，他们不得不把字幕打在屏幕上。她耳语道，“O.J. Simpson刚才进来了。”然后她说，“你听到我说话了吗？O.J. Simpson就在你身后。”和她在一起的那个男人瞥了一眼，然后他们继续四处看看。
Another guy did a double take when he saw O.J. And then went back to signing in. Like, be cool, celebrity nearby, who is O.J. Simpson. But a lot of people seem oblivious. It's just one more freaky open house with a topless women on a trampoline and a lot of broken vases. Until finally, O.J. steps in with the catch phrase.
另一个男人在看到O.J.时回头看了看。然后继续签到。就好像是，酷一点，有名人靠近，那是O.J. Simpson。但很多人似乎完全没注意到。这只是又一个诡异的房屋开放日，有个赤裸上身的女人在蹦床上跳，还有很多破碎的花瓶。直到最后，O.J.出场说了那句口头禅。
You've been juiced. I'm O.J. Simpson. There's a camera.
你被Juiced了。我是O.J. Simpson。那里有摄像机。
I know you are.
我知道你是。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You've been juiced. It's a TV show.
你被Juiced了。这是个电视节目。
It just didn't have any payoff of anything. It was just like all set on the whole premise of, something happens and O.J. Simpson. They didn't think it out further than that. And every gag was just based on that premise.
它根本没有任何回报。就像所有前提都建立在某事发生了，而O.J. Simpson在场。他们没想得更远。每个梗都基于那个前提。
Can you believe this guy is here?
你敢相信这家伙在这儿吗？
Yeah, yeah. Because he's that guy.
是的，是的。因为他就是那个家伙。
For real.
真的。
I know. But yet, in the producers' mind, they were like, oh, this is great.
我知道。但制片人却想，哦，这太棒了。
They kind of got into it.
他们有点沉浸其中了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是的，是的，是的。
So other people on the set, they thought, oh, this is going well. This is funny.
所以片场的其他人想，哦，进展顺利。这很有趣。
Oh, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
哦，是的。是的，是的，是的，是的。
I told Harmon that I figured, as I was watching the show, that the producers had just edited out any moments where people got annoyed or uncomfortable when they got juiced, or pulled away when O.J. went to hug them, or recoiled. And I was completely wrong about that. Harmon told me that during the two weeks of filming, as far as he could remember, no one reacted that way. Other people on the set told me the same thing. There were no moments like that to cut out.
我告诉Harmon，我在看节目时想，制片人肯定是剪掉了人们感到烦躁或不舒服、当人们被Juice时避开，或者当O.J.去拥抱他们时后退的时刻。我完全错了。Harmon告诉我，在两周的拍摄过程中，据他所知，没有人那样反应。片场的其他人也告诉了我同样的事情。没有那样的时刻需要剪掉。
I thought, oh, man, there's going to be like just outraged people, or people freaking out. And that was actually the most mind numbing part about the two-week production, was that people just were actually thrilled when they find out they'd been juiced by O.J.
我以为，哦，天哪，肯定会有愤怒的人，或者崩溃的人。而这其实是那两周拍摄中最令人麻木的部分，就是人们在发现自己被O.J.给Juice后，实际上感到非常激动。
I got juiced!
我被Juiced了！
I've been juiced.
我被Juiced了。
(SINGING) I've been juiced.
（唱歌）我被Juiced了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You know, like we were in Las Vegas filming, and people would just swarm in off the streets to get photos with O.J. Like mothers and daughters requesting photos. This kid, he started rapping for O.J. And then he high fives his friend, and he goes, I just rapped for O.J., man. That's as big as it gets! And it was like, they would just be laughing. It was like, whoa-o-o. Hope he doesn't kill anyone while we're here! Ha ha ha.
你知道，就像我们在拉斯维加斯拍摄时，人们会从街上蜂拥而至，和O.J.合影。就像母亲和女儿要求合影。有个孩子，他开始为O.J.即兴说唱。然后他和他朋友击掌，说，我刚才为O.J.说唱了，伙计。这简直太棒了！就像是，他们只会笑。就像是，哇喔。希望我们在这儿的时候他没杀任何人！哈哈哈。
Did anyone say anything like that?
有人说过那样的话吗？
I would hear people off to the side saying that, but they wouldn't say it like angry. They would say it like, oh, he's just funny O.J. who-- he just like became like-- he's like this funny cartoon character. He's like the Santa Claus of murder.
我听到旁边的人那样说，但他们不会生气地那样说。他们会说，哦，他只是有趣的O.J.，他变成了像——他变成了像这样一个有趣的卡通人物。他就像谋杀界的圣诞老人。
Whatever charisma was working in person doesn't come across on the screen. In fact, let me step briefly outside Harmon's story of what it's like to make Juiced to talk more about what it's like to watch Juiced. I've shown this now to so many people, and the sheer scope of the chaos in the show is disorienting. Not just to me. Watching the show feels like being winked at from across the room by someone who may be flirting with you, or may be messing with you, or may just have a tic. It's not clear what to make of anything that's happening.
无论现场有什么个人魅力，在屏幕上都体现不出来。事实上，让我稍微跳出Harmon讲述的《Juiced》制作过程，更多地谈谈观看《Juiced》的感觉。我现在给很多人看过这个，节目中混乱的范围令人不知所措。不仅仅是对我。看这个节目感觉就像有人从房间另一头对你挤眉弄眼，那个人可能是在调情，可能是在捉弄你，或者可能只是抽动。不知道该如何理解正在发生的事情。
In between the pranks in Juiced , there's a scene-changing package that includes, for some reason, a gunshot sound effect--
在《Juiced》的恶作剧之间，有一个换场包，出于某种原因，包含了一个枪声效果——
[GUN SHOTS]
[枪声]
--whatever that's supposed to mean, or not mean. And 20 to 30 seconds of music, during which O.J. is surrounded by strippers. Sometimes he's rapping, dressed as a pimp-- big fuzzy black hat, zebra striped lapels.
——那意味着什么，或者不意味着什么。以及20到30秒的音乐，期间O.J.被脱衣舞女包围。有时他在说唱，打扮成皮条客——戴着巨大的黑色毛绒帽子，斑马条纹翻领。
(RAPPING) A lot of people wonder about my intentions. Why do people ask me so many questions about how I made it to the top, about all the times I made those people [INAUDIBLE].
（说唱）很多人好奇我的意图。为什么人们问我那么多关于我是如何爬到顶端的问题，关于我让那些人[听不清]的所有那些时刻。
There's pole dancing. They give him lap dances. And again, this scene is in between nearly every prank. And he's surrounded by dancing women who mostly have long, blond hair and don't not resemble his dead ex-wife. And he's mugging to the camera with that expression, like, how great is this? But before you can decide what that means, if anything, besides just the demographics of who was available to shoot this scene, it's on to the next puzzling moment.
有钢管舞。她们给他跳膝上舞。再说一次，这个场景几乎在每个恶作剧之间。他被跳舞的女性包围，她们大多有着长长的金发，长得不不像他死去的那个前妻。他对着摄像机做着表情，好像在说，这难道不棒吗？但在你决定这意味什么之前，如果有什么意义的话，除了当时谁有空拍摄这个场景的人口统计学数据，节目又进入了下一个令人费解的时刻。
For instance, in the open house prank. At one point, Harmon, playing the angry homeowner whose house is being looked at, tries to blame O.J. for breaking one of the vases.
例如，在房屋开放日的恶作剧。有一次，Harmon扮演那个被看房的愤怒房主，试图把花瓶破碎归咎于O.J.。
Did you do this? Can you just pay for my vase, please? Can you just pay for my vase?
是你干的吗？你能赔我的花瓶吗，求你了？你能赔我的花瓶吗？
Sir, I wasn't around. I get blamed for nothing else. All right, in my life, I've been blamed for enough shit.
先生，我不在附近。我无缘无故被指责。好吧，在我的人生中，我已经背够了黑锅。
[VASE SHATTERING]
[花瓶破碎声]
When O.J. Says, "I've been blamed for enough shit," he sounds genuinely angry. Which means, I think, he's mad at being fake blamed for breaking a vase in a prank, because it reminds him that he was on trial for murder 10 years ago. There's a prank where O.J. pretends to be having an affair with another man's wife, and the man gets really angry. There's a prank where O.J. plays himself, but a homeless version of himself, selling bags of oranges by the side of the road.
当O.J.说，“我已经背够了黑锅”时，他听起来非常愤怒。这意味着，我认为，他因为在恶作剧中被假装指责弄碎花瓶而感到愤怒，因为它提醒了他10年前他因为谋杀案受审的事情。有个恶作剧是O.J.假装和别人的妻子有染，那个人非常生气。有个恶作剧是O.J.扮演自己，但是一个无家可归版本的自己，在路边卖橘子袋。
Oranges from O.J.! OJ right here!
O.J.的橘子！就是O.J.就在这儿！
Is that an edgy comment on his fallen status, or just another, look at what this celebrity is willing to do on our reality show moment? No time to think. The show plows onward to smaller moments of just raw unlikableness. In one prank, O.J. is dressed as an employee of a fast food place, and he's working the drive-through window. A woman pulls up in her 40s, maybe early 50s.
这是一个对他地位跌落的尖锐评论，还是只是又一个“看这个名人在我们的真人秀节目中愿意做什么”的时刻？没时间思考。节目继续推进到更多纯粹令人不悦的小时刻。在一个恶作剧里，O.J.打扮成一家快餐店的员工，在汽车穿梭窗口工作。一个40岁左右，可能50出头的女人开车过来。
Large fries, large orange juice.
大份薯条，大份橘子汁。
You sure you want those large fries? You know what they're saying about fast food making you fat.
你确定要那些大份薯条吗？你知道人们是怎么说快餐让你变胖的。
The women who's ordering is overweight, so that's the joke. She's fat. She's ordering fries. In Juiced , O.J. has plunged himself into reality TV, a genre that has no allegiance to the idea that the star has to come out looking good. But there's something off about this show that goes beyond that.
那个点餐的女人超重，所以这就是笑点。她很胖。她在点薯条。在《Juiced》中，O.J.把自己沉浸在真人秀中，这个流派对明星必须表现出良好形象的观点没有任何忠诚度。但这个节目确实有些不对劲，超出了这一点。
For all the frenzy on the screen, all the invitations to gawk, or be titillated, or outraged, or just shake your head in wonder, mostly it felt empty. It's tiring to watch, strangely tiring.
尽管屏幕上充满了狂热，所有的邀请去围观，去被刺激，去被激怒，或者只是摇着头感到困惑，但大部分时间它感觉是空的。看起来很累，奇怪地累人。
When I talked to Harmon, he said that during the filming, there were moments unlike any other reality show he'd worked on, unsurprisingly. For starters, as far as he could tell, everyone had been told the same thing he had-- don't bring up the murders or anything related to them. And no one did, except O.J. Before one prank, O.J. was being made up to look like an 81-year-old white man. The makeup took three hours to apply.
当我和Harmon交谈时，他说在拍摄期间，确实有一些时刻与他参与过的任何其他真人秀都不同，这并不奇怪。首先，据他所知，每个人都被告知了同样的事情——不要提起谋杀案或与之相关的任何事情。没人提起，除了O.J.。在一个恶作剧之前，O.J.被化妆成一个81岁的白人老头。化妆过程花了三个小时。
While he's getting the makeup applied, he has the TV turned to Court TV. You know, and I was like, don't mention O.J., Court TV. Don't mention O.J.
当他化妆的时候，他把电视转到了Court TV（法庭频道）。你知道，我就像，别提到O.J.，Court TV。别提到O.J.。
He's saying this to the TV?
他是对着电视说这个吗？
No, no. I'm saying this to myself. Like, oh Court TV, please don't mention O.J. Because I don't know how he would react. But he was actually just like-- he kind of wanted them to mention him. He was like, how are they going to work me into this, you know? You know, during my trial, my lawyers watched my back. You know?
不，不。我是对自己说。就像，哦Court TV，请别提到O.J.。因为我不知道他会如何反应。但他其实只是——他有点希望他们提到他。他说，他们会怎么把我加到这个里面，你知道吗？你知道，在我审判期间，我的律师守着我的背。你知道吗？
So he would-- OK. So it was sort of reminiscing.
所以他会——好的。所以那是一种回忆。
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
While the women are putting the makeup on him.
当女人们在他脸上化妆时。
Yep. He said he really liked watching Court TV.
是的。他说他真的很喜欢看Court TV。
Again, when he was getting the makeup applied, he would actually tell O.J. jokes. So we had the pleasure of hearing like O.J. Jokes from O.J. himself.
再说一次，当他化妆时，他甚至会自己讲O.J.的笑话。所以我们有幸听到了O.J.亲自讲O.J.的笑话。
What's an O.J. joke?
什么是O.J.笑话？
He actually said this. He goes, who's the first Jewish guy to get a Heisman Trophy? Fred Goldman, because he's got mine.
他竟然说了这个。他说，第一个拿到海斯曼奖杯的犹太人是谁？Fred Goldman，因为他拿走了我的。
Because the Goldmans brought a civil suit against him that--
因为Goldman家对他提起了民事诉讼，那——
Yeah, and took his--
是的，拿走了他的——
Money.
钱。
Heisman. And so, you know, everyone just kind of uncomfortably just shifted around and looked at their shoes and contemplated career choices.
海斯曼奖杯。所以，你知道，每个人都尴尬地挪动着，看着自己的鞋子，思考职业选择。
The cinematographer of Juiced , Luc Nicknair, told me there was a split in the crew. Some people thought, look, this man was a great athlete and a big star. And he was acquitted. And that's that, and that's how I see this. And others who thought, yeah, he was acquitted, but I still have other thoughts about what may have happened.
《Juiced》的摄影师Luc Nicknair告诉我，摄制组内部存在分裂。有些人认为，听着，这个男人是一位伟大的运动员和巨星。他被判无罪了。就是这样，我就是这么看待的。其他人则认为，是的，他被判无罪了，但我对可能发生的事情仍有其他想法。
Definitely two schools of thought.
确实有两种思想流派。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
Yeah. There are definitely two schools of thought.
是的。确实有两种思想流派。
And would people argue about it?
人们会对此争论吗？
He talked about it privately. Actually, at the end of the shoot, this was the really messed up thing. They decided to shoot interviews with everyone of the crew about our experiences. And then, at the end of the interview, they would say, guilty or not guilty?
他私下里谈过这个。事实上，在拍摄结束时，这是一件非常糟糕的事情。他们决定拍摄对所有摄制组人员关于我们经历的采访。然后，在采访结束时，他们会问，有罪还是无罪？
Oh my God.
哦，天哪。
That did not get on the DVD. None of that got on the DVD.
那部分没上DVD。那些都没上DVD。
And what was--
那是——
I'm on camera myself.
我自己就在摄像机前。
What did you say?
你说了什么？
Guilty.
有罪。
And is that what you thought going in?
那就是你进去时的想法吗？
I didn't know what to think. That's why I did the job. You know, I secretly want to know. It's like-- and here I was going to be given an opportunity to go and shoot this deranged project, and I decided to do the gig.
我不知道该想什么。这就是为什么我做那份工作。你知道，我私下里想知道。就像——而这里我将获得机会去拍摄这个疯狂的项目，我决定接这个工作。
I mean, I thought about that when I was involved with it. I thought about that. It's like, people are going to study this project. And all of a sudden, you called me 10 years later. [LAUGHS] You know?
我是说，当我参与其中时我也想过。我思考过。就像，人们会研究这个项目。然后突然间，你10年后给我打电话。[笑] 你知道吗？
Harmon, and Luc also, said Las Vegas, where they did the second week of shooting, is where things really turned sour and dark.
Harmon和Luc也说，拉斯维加斯，他们拍摄第二周的地方，事情真的变得酸涩和黑暗。
They just seemed to sort of give up on ideas. And O.J. just got less and less interested in it. He didn't show up. And then we showed up, he was just like really drunk. Like O.J. was supposed to play a wacky motel clerk. You know? Like look out, here comes wacky motel clerk O.J.! You know, that's the premise of that gag. But he was just like completely drunk, and that was the first time they just sort of propped him up in the corner, like on a stool, and just let him be sort of near the pranks.
他们似乎放弃了想法。O.J.也变得越来越不感兴趣。他不出现。然后我们出现，他只是喝得很醉。比如O.J.本应扮演一个怪异的汽车旅馆前台。你知道吗？就像当心，怪异的汽车旅馆前台O.J.来了！你知道，那是那个恶作剧的前提。但他只是完全喝醉了，那是他们第一次把他在角落里撑起来，比如坐在凳子上，只让他待在恶作剧附近。
Harmon said he, Harmon, ended up playing the wacky motel clerk. And sometimes, he even had to be the one to tell people, you've been juiced! Whatever that means, when the person doing it is not O.J. Simpson.
Harmon说他，Harmon，最后扮演了怪异的汽车旅馆前台。有时，他甚至不得不成为那个告诉人们“你被Juiced了！”的人。无论那是意味着什么，当做那件事的人不是O.J. Simpson时。
After I juice a couple, O.J.'s in the corner, drunk. And he would lean into the couple, go, hey, I'm O.J. Hey, do you recognize me?
在我Juiced了一对夫妇后，O.J.在角落里，喝醉了。他会凑向那对夫妇，说，嘿，我是O.J.。嘿，你认出我了吗？
O.J. Simpson's lawyer, who handles media requests, didn't respond to my emails and phone calls about Juiced. I did reach the executive producer of Juiced, Rick Mahr. We talked on the phone-- after months of unanswered voicemails, texts, and emails from us, then, out of the blue, a legal document from him, just a little heads up. Then a series of very friendly but off the record conversations, mixed in with two taped interviews that he only agreed to if he could approve every quote. So here's what he approved.
O.J. Simpson的律师，处理媒体请求的人，没有回复我关于《Juiced》的电子邮件和电话。我确实联系到了《Juiced》的执行制片人Rick Mahr。我们在电话里谈了——在几个月无人接听的语音信箱、短信和电子邮件之后，突然，他发来一份法律文件，只是一个小小的提醒。接着是一系列非常友好但非正式的谈话，夹杂着两次录音采访，他只同意在他能批准每一个引语的情况下进行。所以这是他批准的内容。
He said, "I had it all wrong when I called Juiced the worst celebrity comeback vehicle ever made."
他说，“当我称《Juiced》为史上最差的名人复出工具时，我完全错了。”
It was never meant to be a comeback vehicle for O.J. or try to turn him into a mainstream star again. We were tasked with creating a reality show that cut through the clutter, that everybody would be talking about, really during an era when there was a reality TV boom, and there was a lot of one upsmanship in the marketplace.
它从来不是为了O.J.复出而设计的，也不是试图让他再次成为主流明星。我们的任务是制作一个突破混乱的真人秀，每个人都会谈论它，确实是在一个真人秀繁荣的时代，市场上有大量的竞争。
He said the goal was just to let the cameras run, whether O.J. looked good or not. He said the show being a pile on of one thing after another that may or may not make sense-- the blond strippers, the dead-end pranks, the weird little verite moments-- that's not a fumble. It's exactly what they were going for. Their business model was get people talking, so pile it on.
他说目标只是让摄像机运行，不管O.J.看起来好不好。他说这个节目是一堆接一堆可能或可能没有意义的事情——金发脱衣舞女、死胡同的恶作剧、奇怪的小真实时刻——那不是失误。这正是他们追求的。他们的商业模式是让人谈论，所以堆上去吧。
He said, look, this wasn't designed to win Emmys. It's supposed to be a nonstop barrage of craziness.
他说，看，这不是为了赢艾美奖而设计的。它应该是一阵不停的疯狂轰炸。
You know, I'd be the first to say it. It's not everybody's-- it's not everybody's cup of tea.
你知道，我会第一个说出来的。这不是每个人的——这不是每个人的菜。
Nielson, the ratings organization, told me the Juiced DVD sold fewer than 100 copies, one of which I own. Rick told me, yeah. He buried the project on purpose.
尼尔森，收视率组织，告诉我《Juiced》DVD的销量不到100份，其中一张归我所有。Rick告诉我，是的。他故意埋葬了这个项目。
We had the blinders on to make one crazy reality TV show. After we did it-- and I think we did that-- after we did it, there was a part of me that said, what the hell did we just do?
我们戴着眼罩去制作一个疯狂的真人秀。在我们做完之后——而且我认为我们做到了——在我们做完之后，我的一部分说，我们到底做了什么？
Juiced was coming out around the same time that O.J. released a book called If I Did It . Huge outcry. The woman who was publishing the book lost her job. A two-hour Fox special was canceled.
《Juiced》在O.J.出版一本名为《If I Did It》（如果我做了）的书的同时推出。引起了巨大的强烈抗议。那名出版这本书的女人丢了工作。福克斯的两个小时特别节目被取消了。
And we pulled it. We pulled it from circulation. And it's been gathering dust until now.
我们撤下了它。我们把它从流通中撤下了。直到现在它还在积灰。
Yeah. You were surprised when I told you that I had a copy.
是的。当我告诉你我有副本时你很惊讶。
I was.
我很惊讶。
Rick is now re-releasing the Juiced material with footage that's never been seen and an interview with O.J. From the time. It's called O.J. Un gloved , the Lost Tapes . He's got the domain name ojsimpson.com. Makes sense-- the 20th anniversary of the murder trial verdict is coming up this fall. There's a multipart FX miniseries in the works. Cuba Gooding Junior is playing O.J. They filmed the Bronco scene a few weeks ago.
Rick现在正在重新发布《Juiced》的材料，包括从未见过的片段和对O.J.的采访。是从那个时候开始的。它叫《O.J. Ungloved, the Lost Tapes》。他有域名 ojsimpson.com。有道理——谋杀案审判判决20周年纪念即将来临。FX正在制作一部多集迷你剧。Cuba Gooding Jr.扮演O.J.。几周前他们拍摄了Bronco场景。
Rick didn't want to say if Juiced was O.J.'s idea or not. When I asked if O.J. was paid for it, he said, O.J. did this because he wanted to do it. He said his understanding is that O.J. did see Juiced , every frame, and approved it before it went out. When I asked Rick if O.J. had ever said, look, this is how I want to be portrayed in this show, Rick said the answers to what O.J. wanted out of Juiced , or why he did it in the first place, are locked in O.J.'s head. All he, Rick, could say is how unworried O.J. seemed to him while they were filming, like anyway they put the footage together would be great, because it was O.J.
Rick不想说《Juiced》是不是O.J.的主意。当我问O.J.是否为此得到报酬时，他说，O.J.做这个是因为他想做。他说他的理解是，O.J.确实看了《Juiced》，每一帧，并在它发布前批准了。当我问Rick O.J.是否曾经说过，看，这就是我想在这个节目中被描绘的方式，Rick说关于O.J.想从《Juiced》中得到什么，或者他起初为什么这么做的答案，都锁在O.J.的脑袋里。他，Rick，唯一能说的是，在拍摄时O.J.看起来多么不担心，好像他们把片段拼在一起的方式都会很棒，因为那是O.J.。
I think history has shown that O.J. Simpson is his own boss. And O.J. is going to do what O.J. is going to do.
我认为历史表明O.J. Simpson是他自己的老板。O.J.会做他想做的事。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
[INAUDIBLE] O.J. Simpson is with us. You ever had any trouble-- speeding tickets, that kind of thing-- O.J.?
[听不清] O.J. Simpson和我们在一起。你有没有遇到过麻烦——超速罚单，那种事情——O.J.？
I don't know if I should say this. I got stopped--
我不知道我是否应该说这个。我被拦下了——
This is O.J. on The Letterman Show in 1989, five years before Nicole Simpson and Ron Goldman were found murdered. And I'm just playing it because, listen to how big his world was back then, how the audience loves everything he says.
这是1989年O.J.在Letterman秀上，在Nicole Simpson和Ron Goldman被发现被谋杀的前五年。我播放它只是因为，听听那时他的世界有多大，观众多爱他说的每一句话。
And I decided that nobody else was on the road. And I was going like-- I think I got it up-- oh, you don't want to hear this, do you?
我决定路上没别人。我正开着——我想我开到了——哦，你不想听这个，对吧？
Yeah, no. Let's just--
是的，不。我们还是——
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
I got it up pretty fast. I got it up to about 170 miles an hour.
我开得很快。我开到了大约170英里每小时。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
And uh--
呃——
Give me your license. Give me your license right now! 170?
给我看你的驾照。现在给我你的驾照！170？
Well, and then, this car is really safer. [INAUDIBLE]
嗯，然后，这辆车真的很安全。[听不清]
Oh, man.
哦，天哪。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉谈话]
It really is [INAUDIBLE] 100.
它确实是 [听不清] 100。
You should have been with me this morning.
你今天早上应该和我在一起的。
I bet that, to a very famous person, losing the love of the general public feels the way aging can feel-- an unfair changing of the rules, too big to accept. And so maybe it's not that surprising that O.J. put himself in a prank show 10 years after the trial, basically saying, remember me? Still charming. Watching Juiced sometimes felt like seeing a beautiful older actress trying to reprise the exact role that had made her famous when she was younger, as though nothing has changed.
我敢打赌，对于一个非常有名的人来说，失去公众的喜爱感觉就像衰老一样——一种不公平的规则改变，大到无法接受。所以也许O.J.在审判10年后把自己放进一个恶作剧节目并不奇怪，基本上是在说，还记得我吗？还是很迷人。看《Juiced》有时感觉就像看到一个美丽的年长女演员试图重演她年轻时让她成名的角色，好像什么都没变一样。
Remember earlier I talked about Juiced feeling empty? How the show keeps urging viewers to be scandalized and outraged, but mostly I just felt tired watching it? I think I figured out why while I was watching and rewatching this last scene I want to play for you, the most stunning one in Juiced. It starts with O.J. explaining the prank that's about to happen, which takes place at a used car lot.
记得之前我谈到《Juiced》感觉很空吗？节目如何不断敦促观众去感到丑闻和愤怒，但我看的时候大部分只觉得累？我想我在观看和重温我想为你播放的最后一个场景时弄明白了，这是《Juiced》中最令人震惊的一个。它以O.J.解释即将发生的恶作剧开始，发生在二手车行。
I actually sold the worst used car ever. And this was a Bronco, with a bullet hole in it, and seats with holes in it. Watch this.
我实际上卖了有史以来最差的二手车。这是一辆Bronco，上面有个弹孔，座位上有洞。看这个。
Yes. The Bronco. O.J. Is posing as a used car salesman selling a white Bronco. Not the white Bronco, just a white Bronco that, for some reason, has a bullet hole in the side. And while they're filming, O.J. signs his name right above the bullet hole.
是的。Bronco。O.J.假装成一个二手车推销员在卖一辆白色Bronco。不是那辆白色的Bronco，只是一辆白色的Bronco，出于某种原因，侧面有一个弹孔。当他们在拍摄时，O.J.在弹孔上方签上了自己的名字。
Now, this is a Bronco signed by O.J. Simpson.
现在，这是一辆由O.J. Simpson签名的Bronco。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
[INAUDIBLE] bullet hole in it.
[听不清] 上面有个弹孔。
Oh.
哦。
The scene is a mishmash of people who seem to have no idea what's going on and others who bring up random parts of the Bronco story or the trial as they remember. And O.J. is just surfing all of it.
场景里混杂着似乎完全不知道在发生什么的人，还有其他人提到Bronco故事或审判的随机部分，正如他们记得的那样。O.J.只是在这一切中冲浪。
Is there $10,000 in here?
这里面有10000美元吗？
Nope. Nope. No $10,000--
没。没。没有10000美元——
[INAUDIBLE] you were carrying it, you know?
[听不清] 你带着它，你知道吗？
Naw, naw. They say that. I was carrying about $3.
不，不。他们那么说。我带着大约3美元。
$3?
3美元？
Yeah. That's why they never brought it up in court.
是的。这就是为什么他们从没在法庭上提过它。
A woman shows up to look at the Bronco, so there's some flirting.
一个女人出现看那辆Bronco，所以有一些调情。
And you're gorgeous, incidentally.
顺便说一句，你真漂亮。
Thank you. I appreciate that.
谢谢。我很感激。
When you see a girl in a car like this--
当你看到一个女孩开着这样的车时——
Yeah?
是吗？
--you say, her man ain't doing nothing for her.
——你会说，她的男人没为她做什么。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
You figure you got a chance, right?
你觉得你有机会，对吧？
And after a little of this, a little of that, O.J. Seems to settle down into his sales pitch for the Bronco.
在经历了一点这个，一点那个之后，O.J.似乎安定下来进行他的Bronco推销。
It was good for me.
它对我很好。
Yeah?
是吗？
Got me out of harm's way.
让我脱离了危险。
[INAUDIBLE] OK, I'll sit in it. [INAUDIBLE] there was a dead body in there.
[听不清] 好的，我会坐进去。[听不清] 那里有一具尸体。
Yeah. Well, um, hopefully there's no bodies in this thing. And I can guarantee you, the car has escape-ability. I mean, if you're ever getting into some trouble, and you've got to get away, it has escape-ability.
是的。嗯，希望这里面没有尸体。而且我可以向你保证，这辆车有“逃跑能力”。我的意思是，如果你遇到麻烦，你必须离开，它有逃跑能力。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
A car that I personally made famous. It has escape-ability. That's the main thing. And I know it. Boy, [INAUDIBLE] was driving this thing. And if we wanted to get away, it was easy to get away.
一辆我亲自让它出名的车。它有逃跑能力。那是主要的。我知道。伙计，[听不清] 正在开这辆车。如果我们想离开，很容易离开。
It's interesting, because he did this thing with the Ford Bronco, which blew us away.
这很有趣，因为他做了那件事与福特Bronco有关，这让我们大吃一惊。
This is Luc, the cinematographer, again.
这是Luc，摄影师，再次发言。
And signs it.
并签名。
He keeps talking about how it has "great escape-ability."
他一直说它有“很棒的逃跑能力”。
Uh-huh. And they milked it, didn't they?
嗯哼。他们利用了这一点，不是吗？
Did he ad-lib that?
他即兴创作的吗？
Yes, he did.
是的，他即兴创作的。
And so, I mean, all of the moments over the course of the show, and the different pranks where he's referring to other points in his life-- to the Hertz commercials and to his sports career, but also to the trial and to the murders--
所以，我的意思是，在节目过程中所有的时刻，以及他提到他生命中其他点的不同恶作剧——对他赫兹广告和他运动生涯的提及，但也对他审判和谋杀的提及——
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
--was the idea, OK, you know, O.J., throw in a reference here? Or was he just supplying those himself?
——这是个想法，好的，你知道，O.J.，在这里加一个引用？还是他自己提供的？
He was all on his own.
他完全是自己做的。
He just was saying those things.
他只是在说那些话。
That's all him. Oh my gosh, no. That's all him.
那全是他的。哦，天哪，不。那全是他的。
Let's set aside the question of taste. Because the whole scene is freakish on its face, but it's a lot more freakish when you sit it next to what actually happened in the Bronco, the real Bronco. Escape-ability? O.J. Simpson didn't escape anything in the white Bronco. The Bronco is what he stepped out of into police custody. Got him out of harm's way? While he was in the Bronco, he was suicidal. He had a gun to his head.
让我们撇开品味问题不谈。因为整个场景本身就很诡异，但当你把它和Bronco，真正的Bronco里发生的事情放在一起时，它就更诡异了。逃跑能力？O.J. Simpson在白色Bronco里什么都没逃脱。Bronco是他下车进入警察监护的地方。让他脱离危险？当他在Bronco里时，他有自杀倾向。他拿着枪指着自己的头。
I want to play you a recording. It's not so well known. It didn't become public until a year and a half after the trial. It's what O.J. Simpson was saying while he was in the Bronco. It's conversations between him and an LAPD detective named Tom Lange, who reached him on his cell phone. O.J. didn't know he was being recorded. He's not performing for an audience. And a warning-- this is a suicidal person talking at length about wanting to kill himself.
我想给你播放一段录音。它不太出名。直到审判一年半后它才公开。这是O.J. Simpson在Bronco里时说的话。这是他和一位叫Tom Lange的洛杉矶警察局侦探之间的对话，他通过手机联系到了他。O.J.不知道他被录音了。他没有为观众表演。一个警告——这是一个有自杀倾向的人在详细谈论想自杀。
Just throw the gun out the window.
把枪扔出窗外。
For me. This is not to keep you guys away from me.
为了我。这不是为了让你们远离我。
I know that.
我知道。
It's for me.
这是为了我。
Nobody's going to hurt you.
没人会伤害你。
This is for me.
这是为了我。
OK. It's for you. I know that. But think of your kids.
好的。这是为了你。我知道。但想想你的孩子。
Yeah.
是的。
Please, just toss it out. You're scaring everybody, man.
求你了，把它扔出去。你吓坏所有人了，伙计。
Aw, I'm not going to hurt anybody.
哦，我不会伤害任何人。
I know you're not going to hurt anybody, but--
我知道你不会伤害任何人，但是——
[INAUDIBLE] for me. I can't take this.
[听不清] 为了我。我受不了了。
Oh yes, you can. Yes, you can.
哦，是的，你可以。是的，你可以。
I can't.
我受不了。
You've got your whole family out here.
你有你的全家人在这里。
I can't take this.
我受不了了。
They love you, man. Don't throw this away. Don't do this. Just throw it out the window.
他们爱你，伙计。别扔掉这一切。别这么做。把它扔出窗外。
Uh--
呃——
And nobody's going to get hurt.
没人会受伤。
I'm the only one that deserves it.
我是唯一一个应得的人。
No, you don't deserve that.
不，你不应得那个。
I'ma get hurt.
我会受伤的。
You do not deserve to get hurt. You do not deserve to get hurt. Don't do this.
你不应得受伤。你不应得受伤。别这么做。
All I did was love Nicole That's all I did was love her.
我所做的只是爱Nicole。我所做的只是爱她。
I understand.
我理解。
I love everybody. I tried to show everybody my whole life that I love everybody.
我爱每个人。我试图向每个人展示我的一生我都爱每个人。
We know that, and everybody loves you. Especially your family-- your mother, your kids.
我们知道，每个人都爱你。特别是你的家人——你的母亲，你的孩子。
I'm just going to leave. I'm just going to go with Nicole. That's all I'ma do. That's all I'm trying to do.
我只是要离开。我只是要和Nicole一起去。我所做的就是这个。我所做的就是这个。
Hey, listen. Don't give in now.
嘿，听着。现在别放弃。
Ugh. I am so tired.
呃。我太累了。
I know. I know.
我知道。我知道。
I just want to be with Nicole.
我只想和Nicole在一起。
This had to have been one of most terrifying, inconsolable moments of O.J. Simpson's life, as he makes clear with every word, every groan. And watching Juiced , I kept looking for-- not even any specific emotion, but just any sign at all that this event had happened to him. That it affected him in some way. I didn't see one.
这一定是O.J. Simpson一生中最恐怖、最无法安慰的时刻之一，正如他用每一个字、每一次呻吟所清楚表明的那样。看《Juiced》时，我一直在寻找——甚至没有任何特定的情感，只是寻找他经历过这件事的任何迹象。它以某种方式影响了他。我没看到一个。
It was good for me.
它对我很好。
Yeah?
是吗？
Got me out of harm's way. [LAUGHS] A car that I personally made famous! [INAUDIBLE] was driving this thing. And if we wanted to get away, it was easy to get away.
让我脱离了危险。[笑] 一辆我亲自让它出名的车！[听不清] 正在开这辆车。如果我们想离开，很容易离开。
The way he's talking about the Bronco, there's no trace of what he experienced a decade before inside the Bronco, inside his own head. Instead, he seems to be remembering it, he seems to be seeing it, the same way we remember seeing it-- on TV. Looking at it from above on the highway, as it drove mile after mile. The emptiness in Juiced ? It's O.J. He's not there.
他谈论Bronco的方式，没有他十年前在Bronco里，在他自己脑子里经历过的事情的痕迹。相反，他似乎在回忆它，他似乎在看到它，就像我们记得看到它一样——在电视上。从高速公路上方看着它，随着它行驶了一英里又一英里。《Juiced》里的空虚？那是O.J.。他不在那儿。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our show. Coming up, a video that shows up too soon. And then, it is no longer too soon. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
Nancy Updike是我们节目的制片人之一。接下来，一段过早出现的视频。然后，它就不再过早了。那一分钟来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
This American Life from Ira Glass. Each week we've got a program, of course, which is a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show-- "too soon."
来自Ira Glass的《美国生活》。每周我们都有一个节目，当然，这是一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的不同种类的故事。今天的节目——“太早了”。
So my dad died about 10 years ago, very suddenly. And it was very terrible and shocking.
所以我父亲大约10年前去世了，非常突然。非常可怕和令人震惊。
We were talking about this week's program around the office, and one of our producers, Zoe Chace, remembered this story. It happened when she was right out of college, and she got the call. Her dad, out of the blue, had a heart attack and died. And her best friend, Rosa, came and got Zoe from Ohio, which is where she was living, and brought her back to New York City, where her family was.
我们在办公室讨论这周的节目，我们的一位制片人Zoe Chace想起了这个故事。那发生在大学刚毕业时，她接到了那个电话。她的父亲，出人意料地心脏病发作去世了。她最好的朋友Rosa从俄亥俄州（她当时住的地方）接走了Zoe，把她带回了她的家人所在的纽约市。
And it was awful. You know, it was just grim darkness. But then, somehow like the next day, Rosa was just pulling stuff out of the fridge to feed me with. And she pulls out the butter dish, you know? A glass butter dish. And it just shatters all over the floor.
那很糟糕。你知道，那只是阴沉的黑暗。但然后，不知何故就像第二天，Rosa只是从冰箱里拿出东西来喂我。她拿出了黄油盘，你知道吗？玻璃黄油盘。它在地板上打碎了。
You mean she drops it.
你是说她摔了它。
She drops it. And I just look at her, and I'm like, that was my dad's. (LAUGHING) It was just-- I was like, horrified! And my sister starts laughing, and I started laughing. Because it's not my dad's. It's just like a crappy butter dish from IKEA. And it was the first-- I think it was the first joke I remember. I remember it as the first joke of when my dad died.
她摔了它。我只是看着她，我心想，那是我的父亲的。（笑）我简直——我简直——我惊呆了！我妹妹开始笑，我也开始笑。因为它不是我父亲的。它只是宜家那种破黄油盘。那是第一——我想是我记得的关于父亲去世的第一件笑话。我把它记得是父亲去世后的第一个笑话。
How many days?
多少天？
It was like a day. It was like the day after.
就像一天。就像第二天。
So the whole idea of-- you know the old saying, comedy equals tragedy plus time, there was no time at all.
所以那个关于——你知道那句老话，喜剧等于悲剧加时间，那时根本没有时间。
Not at all. Yeah.
根本没有。是的。
There's a study where scientists actually tried to quantify exactly how much time has to pass after tragedy before comedy kicks in. And although nothing is more tedious than people sitting around theorizing about what is funny, it's interesting to see somebody get super brass tacks about this and try to actually define this thing that our whole program is about today. These researchers had over 1,000 people rate how funny some joke tweets about Hurricane Sandy were at different points in time. And before the hurricane hit land, people thought the tweets were funny. And then, unsurprisingly, while the hurricane was destroying homes, and knocking out power, and killing people, and in the immediate aftermath of all that, the tweets did not seem funny and in fact seemed kind of offensive.
有一个研究，科学家们实际上试图量化悲剧发生后喜剧出现需要多少时间。虽然没有什么比人们坐在一起理论什么是有趣的更乏味的了，但看到有人对此变得超级务实并试图真正定义这个我们今天整个节目的主题很有趣。这些研究人员让超过1000人对一些关于飓风桑迪的有趣推文在不同时间点进行了评分。在飓风登陆之前，人们认为推文很有趣。然后，不出所料，当飓风摧毁房屋、切断电力并杀人时，以及在所有这些的直接后果中，推文看起来并不有趣，事实上看起来有点冒犯。
And then, it took-- they have a number-- it took 15 days. 15 days after the hurricane struck, the tweets started to seem funny again. Because the researchers-- Peter McGraw, Lawrence Williams, and Caleb Warren-- theorize for something like this to be funny, it has to seem threatening, but not too threatening. Once it stops being threatening, it stops being funny. And in fact, there comes a point after the storm struck-- it is 36 days after the storm struck-- that people start finding the tweets less and less funny.
然后，它花了——他们有一个数字——它花了15天。飓风袭击后的15天，推文开始看起来又很有趣了。因为研究人员——Peter McGraw, Lawrence Williams, 和 Caleb Warren——理论认为要让这样的事情有趣，它必须看起来有威胁，但不要太有威胁。一旦它不再有威胁，它就不再有趣了。事实上，在飓风袭击后有一个点——是袭击后36天——人们开始发现推文越来越不有趣了。
And, to get back to Zoe, Zoe says, yeah, it was only a day after her dad's death that she joked about the butter dish. But the worst had already happened. The threat had past. If her dad had been alive and in imminent danger of dying, she said she couldn't have made the joke, wouldn't have had the impulse to.
而且，回到Zoe，Zoe说，是的，在父亲去世后仅一天，她就开了黄油盘的玩笑。但最坏的情况已经发生了。威胁已经过去了。如果她的父亲还活着且处于死亡的迫在眉睫的危险中，她说她不可能开这个玩笑，不会有冲动。
Because that just sounds so scary, that that would be all you were doing, is being afraid. But now, or right at that moment that I was in--
因为那听起来太可怕了，那将是你正在做的一切，就是感到害怕。但现在，或者就在我所处的那一刻——
Immediately after he died.
在他去世后立即。
Immediately after. I mean, nobody had been themselves, or said anything funny, or laughed about anything. It was super helpful.
去世后立即。我是说，没有人表现得像他们自己，或者说了任何有趣的事，或者嘲笑任何事情。这超级有帮助。
Helpful how?
如何有帮助？
Because I felt like myself, and it felt like my family. You know, we're not such a sincere group of people. And so to have that level of sincere emotion was pretty uncomfortable.
因为我感觉像我自己，这感觉像我的家人。你知道，我们不是那种真诚的群体。所以有那种程度的真诚情感非常不舒服。
[CHUCKLES] Wow. This has gotten so real.
[笑] 哇。这变得太真实了。
[CHUCKLES]
[笑]
Which brings us to this next story of a family, and something being too soon, and then knowing the right moment for the something to happen. We've arrived at Act 2 of our program. Act two, Pink Slip. When Amy Silverman was in her 20s, she had this friend who would go to LA sometimes and bring back these videos. And Amy and her friends would show the videos at parties. On VHS-- this is way back in the prehistoric days, before YouTube.
这把我们带到了下一个关于家庭的故事，有些事情太早了，然后知道事情发生正确的时间。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，解雇通知。Amy Silverman在20多岁时，有这个朋友有时会去洛杉矶带回这些视频。Amy和她的朋友会在派对上放这些视频。在VHS上——那是很久以前的史前时代，在YouTube之前。
This was the '90s. But in Phoenix. So it's probably like the '80s somewhere else.
那是90年代。但在凤凰城。所以它在别处可能是80年代。
And one of the films the guy would bring around to parties was called Pink Slip . Amy says she easily saw it a half dozen times, maybe it was more like a dozen. It always killed. Everybody liked it. It was an instructional video, and its lead character was this girl named Jill, who was just reaching puberty.
那家伙带到派对上的电影之一叫《Pink Slip》（解雇通知）。Amy说她至少看了半打次，也许更像是一打。它总是很火。每个人都喜欢它。这是一个教学视频，主角是一个叫Jill的女孩，她刚刚进入青春期。
I've never been able to figure out when exactly it was made. But probably like late '60s, early '70s. Kind of groovy living room, and they have very outdated hair. Very, very obviously staged. And that was what was so funny about it, really.
我从来没能弄清楚它到底是什么时候制作的。但大概像60年代末，70年代初。有点时髦的客厅，他们的发型非常过时。非常，非常明显是安排好的。那正是它如此有趣的原因，真的。
The film was about menstruation. And so if you're listening with a little kid right now, and you do not want to get into that subject with them right this second, take that into advisement. OK, here's a clip.
电影是关于月经的。所以如果你现在和一个小孩子在听，而你不希望立刻和他们谈论那个话题，请注意这一点。好的，这是一个片段。
Susie, do you have periods?
Susie，你有月经吗？
Do I have periods? Jill, all women have periods about every four weeks for three or four days. When I'm on my period, blood from inside of my body comes outside from an opening between my legs.
我有月经吗？Jill，所有女性大约每四周有三到四天的月经。当我来月经时，我体内的血液从我双腿之间的一个开口流到外面。
Well, Susie, what about my teacher? Does Miss Jones have periods?
嗯，Susie，那我的老师呢？Miss Jones有月经吗？
Yes, Jill. Your teacher, Mrs. Jones, does have periods. All women have periods about every four weeks for three or four days.
是的，Jill。你的老师，Mrs. Jones，确实有月经。所有女性大约每四周有三到四天的月经。
Hi, girls.
嗨，女孩们。
Hi, Dad.
嗨，爸爸。
What have you girls been talking about?
女孩们在谈论什么？
About periods, Daddy! Dad, does Aunt Carol have periods?
关于月经，爸爸！爸爸，Carol姨妈有月经吗？
Yes, Jill. All women have periods about every four weeks.
是的，Jill。所有女性大约每四周有月经。
So it's very repetitive.
所以非常重复。
And we would watch it and shriek with laughter. Not proud of it, but that is what happened. A lot.
我们会看它并尖叫着大笑。不以为傲，但这就是发生了什么。很多。
Blood from inside a woman's body comes outside, from an opening between her legs, about every four weeks.
女性体内的血液从她双腿之间的一个开口流出来，大约每四周一次。
But the blood? Won't it get on my clothes?
但血呢？它不会弄脏我的衣服吗？
No, it won't. Because you use a sanitary pad.
不，不会。因为你使用卫生巾。
A sanitary pad.
卫生巾。
Amy says it did register with her that there was something up with that girl, Jill. Something different. But she never really gave it much thought. And she and her friends would drink, and they'd watch this kitschy old film. And years later, when Amy was 37, she had her second child-- a daughter, Sophie. And Sophie had Down Syndrome.
Amy说她确实意识到那个女孩，Jill，有点问题。有点不同。但她从来没怎么多想。她和她的朋友会喝酒，她们会看这部老土的电影。几年后，当Amy 37岁时，她有了第二个孩子——一个女儿，Sophie。Sophie患有唐氏综合症。
So when Sophie was like two weeks old, all of a sudden I was driving down the street one day, and I went, oh my god, Pink Slip ! And suddenly, it all came together for me, and I realized that that video had been about a girl with Down Syndrome. And now I had a baby with Down Syndrome. And some day, I was going to have to figure out how to teach her about puberty. And then, as quickly as that thought came into my head, I shoved it out and replaced it with, I don't know, a need for diapers or something.
所以当Sophie两周大时，突然有一天我开车在街上，我心想，哦，天哪，《Pink Slip》！突然，一切都连接起来了，我意识到那个视频是关于一个患有唐氏综合症的女孩。而现在我有一个患有唐氏综合症的宝宝。总有一天，我得想办法教她关于青春期的事情。然后，当那个想法进入我的脑海时，我立刻把它挤了出去，换成了，我不知道，尿布的需求之类的。
Years pass, and by the time Sophie was 10, she had seen her older sister become an adolescent, and Sophie was obsessed.
岁月流逝，当Sophie 10岁时，她看到她的大姐姐变成了青少年，Sophie痴迷了。
She had a bra collection. She had a deodorant collection.
她有一个胸罩收藏。她有一个除臭剂收藏。
Not that she needed a bra or deodorant just yet, Amy says. There was one false alarm, where it seemed like she was growing hair in new places.
并非她现在需要胸罩或除臭剂，Amy说。有一个误报，看起来她在新的地方长了头发。
And she started jumping up and down. She ran down the hallway naked into her sister's room to show her. She grabbed my cell phone and called one of my friends, and she raced around the kitchen table as fast as she could, again and again, you know, just talking about her hair with my mom, with my friend, with my husband.
她开始蹦蹦跳跳。她赤身裸体跑过走廊进她姐姐的房间向她展示。她抓起我的手机打电话给我的朋友，她尽可能快地围着餐桌跑，一遍又一遍，你知道，只是和我的母亲，和我的朋友，和我的丈夫谈论她的头发。
Oh, she really wants to hit puberty.
哦，她真的很想进入青春期。
She really wants to hit puberty.
她真的很想进入青春期。
Amy and her husband decided to enroll Sophie in a class about puberty, a one-time seminar for kids with Down Syndrome, to answer their questions and teach them what they needed to know about what was going to happen to them, taught by this woman who is an expert on all that. And it was OK. It was fine. Though it didn't do the job for Sophie.
Amy和她的丈夫决定给Sophie报一个关于青春期的课程，一个针对唐氏综合症儿童的一次性研讨会，回答他们的问题并教他们需要知道关于即将发生的事情，由这位在这一切方面都是专家的女人教授。这还可以。没问题。虽然它没对Sophie起作用。
Sophie was-- you know, she was about to turn 12, and she was still asking questions.
Sophie是——你知道，她快12岁了，她还在问问题。
What were the questions she was asking?
她在问什么问题？
She wanted to know the basics about her period. About where the blood would come out, what she would use. Just basics. And I thought, you know what? Maybe I should show her Pink Slip.
她想知道关于月经的基础知识。关于血从哪里出来，她会用什么。只是基础知识。我想，你知道吗？也许我应该给她看《Pink Slip》。
This was honestly something she had never considered before. She'd never taken that video seriously.
这诚实地是她以前从未考虑过的事情。她从来没认真对待那个视频。
No. No! We made fun of it. So I got the video up for her, for her to see.
不。不！我们取笑它。所以我为她找到了视频，让她看。
Now, I know you recorded a conversation with her before you showed her the video. Let me just play that piece of tape. Here we go.
现在，我知道你在给她看视频之前录下了和她的谈话。让我播放那段磁带。我们开始吧。
Do you remember what we're talking about today?
你记得我们今天在谈论什么吗？
Periods.
月经。
Yep. And now, do you feel like you already know everything about them?
是的。现在，你觉得你已经知道关于它们的一切了吗？
Yup. Because last year, I had a puberty lesson. And they sang a song-- "Just Around the Corner."
是的。因为去年，我上了一节青春期课。他们唱了一首歌——“就在拐角处”。
She's saying last year they did a puberty lesson, and they sang a song-- "Just Around the Corner." That's how she knows everything. Amy pulled up Pink Slip on her phone because, of course, it's on YouTube.
她说去年他们上了一节青春期课，唱了一首歌——“就在拐角处”。这就是她知道的一切。Amy在她的手机上找到了《Pink Slip》，因为，当然，它在YouTube上。
And, unlike me, Sophie loves to watch videos on YouTube. So she grabbed it and watched it.
而且，不像我，Sophie喜欢在YouTube上看视频。所以她抓起它看了。
And so let's watch the video.
所以我们来看视频吧。
So let's watch the video?
所以我们来看视频？
Yeah.
是的。
OK.
好的。
Yes, what about periods?
是的，关于月经呢？
Do you have periods?
你有月经吗？
In the recording that Amy made of Sophie watching Pink Slip, there is a moment where they both laugh. It's the most shocking moment in the film, and it really is kind of shocking. Again, if you are listening right now with a small child, know that I am about to say something very frank about menstruation. And just decide if you want to keep listening.
在Amy录下的Sophie看《Pink Slip》的录音中，有一个时刻她们都笑了。这是电影中最令人震惊的时刻，它确实有点令人震惊。再说一次，如果你现在和一个小孩在听，知道我即将对月经说一些非常坦率的话。只需决定你是否想继续听。
The moment that Amy and Sophie laugh at in the video is one that Amy remembers very well from back when she used to watch the video with her friends at parties. It's kind of the big moment in the film.
Amy和Sophie在视频中笑的那个时刻，是Amy记得很清楚的，回到她曾经和朋友在派对上看视频的时候。这确实是电影中的大时刻。
Well, this was like the grabber at the parties. Where Jill would say to Susie, you know, I don't understand or something. And Susie would say, well, come into the bathroom with me, Jill. I have my period right now. And then sit down, and pull down her pants, and show her bloody pad.
嗯，这就像派对上的抓手。Jill会对Susie说，你知道，我不明白之类的。Susie会说，好吧，跟我进浴室，Jill。我正来月经呢。然后坐下，拉下裤子，展示她的带血护垫。
This is a used sanitary pad.
这是一片用过的卫生巾。
Look, there's blood on it.
看，上面有血。
See?
看到了吗？
You mean the blood's coming from inside your body now?
你是说血现在正从你的体内出来？
That's right.
那是对的。
[SNICKERS]
[偷笑]
Blood is coming from inside my body through an opening between my legs.
血液正从我体内的开口通过我双腿之间流出来。
For the record, I laughed first.
记录在案，我先笑的。
Yep.
是的。
Just a minute later, after the sister shows the girl in the film how to throw away a used pad and start using a new pad, Sophie watches intently and quietly says--
一分钟后，在电影中的姐姐向女孩展示了如何丢弃用过的护垫并开始使用新护垫后，Sophie专心地看着并安静地说——
I get it now.
我明白了。
Back at the parties that Amy used to go to, when the scene drew the biggest laughs and the most comments, it was just too soon for Amy to get what the video would be good for-- for a girl like Sophie.
回到Amy曾经去的那些派对，当那个场景引起最大的笑声和最多的评论时，Amy太早了，无法理解那个视频对什么有用——对像Sophie这样的女孩。
What was it like watching her watch this video that you knew so well?
看她看你如此熟悉的视频是什么感觉？
Completely surreal. Completely surreal. I mean, embarrassing.
完全超现实。完全超现实。我是说，尴尬。
Why was it embarrassing?
为什么尴尬？
Oh, I was embarrassed because I used to make fun of it.
哦，我很尴尬，因为我曾经取笑它。
But Sophie didn't know that.
但Sophie不知道。
No, but I don't feel like that really honored her. You know? My prior behavior.
不，但我感觉那真的没尊重她。你知道吗？我之前的行为。
Oh, I see what you're saying. Here you are. You've got this little girl who you love. And now, with her present, you're returning to the scene of the crime.
哦，我明白你的意思了。你在这里。你有一个你爱的小女孩。而现在，在她面前，你正在回到犯罪现场。
Yeah. I felt more ashamed than embarrassed. But I had to stop and think, huh, maybe the person who made that video really knew what they were doing.
是的。我感觉比尴尬更羞耻。但我不得不停下来思考，嗯，也许制作那个视频的人真的知道他们在做什么。
Yeah. That's the thing I was wondering, is did it give you a respect for the video?
是的。那是我一直在想的事情，是它让你对视频产生了尊重吗？
It did. It was really weird.
它确实。那真的很奇怪。
And so all the corny repetition in the whole thing, that's totally right for her.
所以整个东西里所有的俗气重复，对她来说是完全正确的。
That's what she needs. It just has to be slowed down. The learning has to be slowed down.
那正是她需要的。它只是需要减慢速度。学习必须减慢速度。
Do you feel like a certain amount of being a parent is realizing what an ass you were before you were a parent?
你觉得成为父母的一部分是意识到在成为父母之前你是个混蛋吗？
Yes. Absolutely. I mean, I was the one who-- I always tell people this. I was the one who would switch lines at Safeway if there was a person with a developmental disability bagging groceries. Because I just didn't want to deal. It would've taken, what? 15 seconds to nod and smile? And be a human being about it? Not me.
是的。绝对。我是说，我就是那个——我总是告诉人们这件事。我就是那个如果有一个残疾人在装杂货，我会切换队伍的人。因为我只是不想处理。那需要，什么？15秒来点头微笑？并为此做一个人类？不是我。
Amy's thought about showing Pink Slip to Sophie again. It's been a few months, and Sophie still has not gotten her period. Though Amy's not sure what Sophie would think of the video today. Because Sophie's able to tell that the girl in the video has Down Syndrome. And Sophie is going through a thing right now where she does not like to identify herself that way.
Amy想再次给Sophie展示《Pink Slip》。已经几个月了，Sophie仍然没有来月经。虽然Amy不确定Sophie今天会对视频有什么看法。因为Sophie能看出视频里的女孩患有唐氏综合症。而Sophie现在经历着一件她不喜欢那样识别自己的事情。
Not to get all serious on you, but Sophie is starting to realize that she's-- she's not going to ever have some of the things that her sister has. So recently, she asked me, am I going to have Down Syndrome when I grow up? And I said, you are. And she said, I don't want to. I don't want to have it.
不谈得太严肃，但Sophie开始意识到她——她永远不会拥有她姐姐拥有的一些东西。所以最近，她问我，我长大后会患有唐氏综合症吗？我说，你会的。她说，我不想要。我不想患有它。
Oh.
哦。
Yeah.
是的。
So what does her sister get that she doesn't get, that she sees right now?
所以她姐姐拥有什么她没拥有，她现在看到的？
She gets to go to a fancy art school that won't take Sophie. She gets to dance on point in ballet, which Sophie doesn't get to do because her feet aren't strong enough. She gets sleepover invitations Sophie doesn't get. And she gets that life in front of her. You know, she-- Sophie told me the other day that she doesn't want to have an aid at school anymore, because she wants to practice walking to class by herself for college.
她可以去一个Sophie不被录取的昂贵艺术学校。她可以在芭蕾舞中跳脚尖舞，Sophie不能做因为她的脚不够强壮。她得到Sophie得不到的过夜邀请。她有那条在她面前的生活。你知道，她——Sophie前几天告诉我，她不想再在学校有助手了，因为她想练习自己走去教室上大学。
What Sophie will get that her sister got, and she'll probably get it pretty soon, is her period. And Amy might show her Pink Slip again. Amy tried once to show the video to Sophie's older sister. And the older sister got to the part with the bloody pad and then tossed the phone back to Amy. But Sophie's different, and she liked the video. Pink Slip was what she needed.
Sophie会得到什么她姐姐得到的，她可能会很快得到，就是月经。Amy可能会再次给她看《Pink Slip》。Amy曾经试过给Sophie的姐姐看视频。姐姐到了带血护垫的部分，然后把手机扔回给Amy。但Sophie不同，她喜欢那个视频。Pink Slip是她需要的。
Our program is produced today by Miki Meek with Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Jonathan Manjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp and Nancy Updike. Our editor is Joel Lovell. Other editing help today from Neil Drumming and Julie Snyder, who's our editorial consultant. Production help from Lily Sullivan. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our office manager. Kimberly Henderson is our office coordinator. Elna Baker scouts stories for our show. Research help today from Christopher Swetala and Michelle Harris. Music help today from Damien Graef and Rob Gettis.
我们的节目今天由Miki Meek制作，Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Jonathan Manjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp 和 Nancy Updike 协助。我们的编辑是 Joel Lovell。今天的其他编辑帮助来自 Neil Drumming 和 Julie Snyder，她是我们的编辑顾问。制作帮助来自 Lily Sullivan。Seth Lind 是我们的运营总监。Emily Condon 是我们的制作经理。Elise Bergerson 是我们的办公室经理。Kimberly Henderson 是我们的办公室协调员。Elna Baker 为我们的节目寻找故事。今天的研究帮助来自 Christopher Swetala 和 Michelle Harris。今天的音乐帮助来自 Damien Graef 和 Rob Gettis。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Amy Silverman blogs about her daughter Sophie at girlinapartyhat.com. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, when he hears the credits to our show begin, every single program, the only thing that goes through his mind is--
Amy Silverman在 girlinapartyhat.com 博客上写关于她女儿Sophie的事情。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由 PRX，公共广播交易所，提供给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的共同创始人，Mr. Torey Malatia。你知道，当他听到我们节目的片尾开始时，每一个节目，唯一闪过他脑海的是——
How are they going to work me into this?
他们会怎么把我加到这个里面？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。